>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Anne E. McLean: Good evening.
I'm Anne McLean from the
library's music division.
Tonight we are very
pleased to presenting --
to be presenting the first
of two concerts features
the musicians from Marlboro.
And as you'll hear in a
conversation, the Marlboro Festival
and its extraordinary
musicians are very much a part
of our concert history here
at the Library of Congress.
With these two concerts, we're
celebrating the 65th anniversary
of the festival, founded in 1951
by legendary artist presented here
in the Coolidge many, many
times in the past century.
Adolf Busch and his brother Hermann
Busch, Rudolf Serkin, Marcel Moyse
and his wife, Blanche Honegger
Moyse and their son, Louis.
And I'd like to introduce three
wonderful artists who are continuing
to Marlboro tradition, cellist Marcy
Rosen, who's appeared her a number
of times and violinist, David
McCarroll and Emilie-Anne Gendron.
Also with us is a good friend
and colleague, Michael Wilpers,
who is a performing arts
programmer for the Bill
and Mary Meyer Concert Series
at the Smithsonian's Freer
and Sackler Galleries.
We are really delighted that Michael
had been very interested with us
in the idea of a joint presentation
for the Marlboro concerts
this season,
which has a particular resonance
for our 90th anniversary.
We had the idea to join forces
this very informal talk,
inspired by all the warm
relationships that grew
out of the founding artist
friendships and connections.
And we'd like to talk about how so
many Marlboro influences have helped
to shape the practice and the
performance of chamber music
over the past six and
a half decades.
In fact, that story of
Marlboro is really the story
of chamber music in America.
Something the library and the Freer
both have a long perspective on.
And both our organizations
have been a part
of that story since its beginning.
The first concert sponsored here
in Washington by our founder,
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge,
were presented
at the Freer in February 1924.
Before we look at some
of this history,
including the American debut by
Serkin and Busch here in 1933,
we wanted to talk with the artists
and set the scene a little bit
about the current Marlboro life
and talk about your experience.
Michael, you had a
question on this for them.
>> Michael Wilpers: Well, one
of the things, I had a chance
to visit Marlboro finally a couple
summers ago and I discovered
that for me, it felt so much more
like a retreat than a festival
in the conventional sense
because it's so far away
out in the mountains and the woods.
And it -- what came to life for
me were quotes I had already read
on the anniversaries of Marlboro
by so many of the artists --
was the unique opportunity
for some of the young artists,
not knowing how unique it was, to
spend very extended lengths of time
on individual pieces in rehearsal.
There's often reiterated quote
in some of the literature
by a young artist who went
to Marlboro and thought,
"I've made the right
career decision.
This is wonderful, we get to work
on pieces for weeks and weeks
and then perform them in public,
only when they're perfect."
And only after leaving Marlboro
and then finally launching
onto a music career, getting
invited to a symphony orchestra
to play a concerto, found out
that he gets one rehearsal
and then we go onstage.
And this was somewhat of a
crushing disappointment and a slap
of reality, but it's -- everyone
at Marlboro speaks about the --
the richness in interpretation
and insight into a piece,
shared insight perfection of a piece
through all the time that's
spent together on them.
So I was hoping that each of you
might reflect on some of the ways
of which that much time on a piece
with such great musicians has
created memorable insights
and routinely gives you a
much, much deeper knowledge
and awareness of a piece.
>> Marcy Rosen: Well,
I guess I'll start.
First of all, nothing's
ever perfect.
But we do have an incredible
luxury of time to spend there
and through -- when you -- and I
have a saying that I like to say,
which is that when you
learn something at Marlboro,
you know it for your lifetime.
And that's true of any piece
that I worked on there as a --
as a student starting
back many years ago.
And the things and the pieces
that I've explored in the time
that I've come back and
been one of the old people,
it's been really incredible.
David and I have spent a
lot of time together there.
We have the luxury of working on
two of Beethoven's late quartets,
the Opus 130 with the fugue and then
the next summer we did Opus 131.
And we spent seven weeks
on each of those pieces
and we had an incredible time
exploring that and learning that,
and being inspired not just
by our own work with it,
but by input that we got from other
people that were at the festival,
like Michael Tree and
Arnold Steinhardt.
And so we had great lessons
with those people and I think
that the idea of sharing ideas
is what Marlboro is really about,
also learning how to
vocalize your own ideas.
And I think that's
really the main gift
that we're given at
-- at the festival.
And so, it's -- it is called
a festival, it is a retreat,
we all live together, we all eat
together, we all get crazy together
and we all get really
grumpy together, a few.
So everybody -- you have to learn
to live with the moods and you --
and live in close quarters and now
we have the outlets of computers
and cell phones, which when I was
there as a kid, we didn't have that.
There was one payphone in each dorm
and I -- we used to write letters.
Remember how we used
to write letters?
Yeah, such a luxury, that's also
something that we don't do anymore,
but it's a -- it's a great place to
-- to be nurtured in a musical way.
>> David McCarroll: As
Marcy said everything
so beautifully, it's hard to add.
But one thing I would
add is just the --
the place itself, the nature I
think is very important to it,
that it's not -- you don't
realize the hectic pace of life
that you know is going on, you know,
for seven weeks at the same time,
but you're just so
far away from that.
And that, you know, I often think
about this, that life is sort
of getting a, you know,
faster and faster pace,
almost uncontrollably so.
And it's just -- obviously when it
was founded 65 years ago, probably,
you know, Serkin could
never even imagined how --
how valuable it is today to
have seven weeks just away
from everything, just
to focus on music.
You don't even have to worry
about food or anything, you --
you know, get up in the morning,
you walk to rehearsal, you have --
have meals with your colleagues
and friends and then you go back
to rehearsing and this just happens
over and over for seven weeks.
And so, inevitably something special
comes out of that -- that process.
>> Emilie-Anne Gendron: Yeah, I
mean, all these things I fully agree
with and yeah, the only thing
I guess I could add is --
well, I guess a couple things.
First of all, Michael,
you mentioned the --
the hypothetical case
of the young person
who has the slap in
the face of reality.
And, you know, after having spent
such luxury of time of working
on pieces and, it's
funny, I think about that
because my experience coming
to Marlboro was actually kind
of the opposite of that
because I was sort of --
well, my time at Marlboro was spent
like in my -- my late
20's basically.
So I'd already sort of been out
of school and, you know, working
and doing concerts and, you know,
I -- by the time I was at Marlboro,
like in my daily life during
the year, I knew pretty well how
to put something together
pretty quickly and to, you know,
create the illusion that I knew
it as well as I possibly did.
But -- but it was actually
kind of an enlightening
and completely shattering experience
for me to have these years --
these summers at Marlboro where
I didn't have to feel that,
like I was constantly under
the gun of having to, you know,
put something together
really quickly and just sort
of like make the product.
It -- it wasn't about that, it
was really just about the exchange
of these ideas and how to
vocalize them, as Marcy said.
And, you know -- yeah, the luxury of
time, it really taught me something
about what it means to approach
music just -- not as a vocation,
but as a thinking musician
who, you know,
lives these pieces
time and time again.
And that's actually one of the big
privileges of having pieces selected
for these musicians from
Marlboro tours that, you know,
we had the luxury of spending
such time on them, so much time,
you know, in a past summer and
then we have time away from it for,
you know, well, in this
case, like two years.
And then we came back to it and
the insights and the things,
at least for myself,
that I -- that I --
that came forth when I sort of
studied it a second time, you know,
that was also like very
eye-opening to just have --
yeah, the luxury of time, but
then also time away from it.
And then, I'm speaking specifically
about the Penderecki piece,
which will be featured tonight.
>> Marcy Rosen: The tours are
always set up around a work
that gets what supposedly is
an extraordinary performance
at the festival, so we don't like
to think that we do things that --
on that level all the time.
But, so we -- we did a nice
performance of the Penderecki
at Marlboro and Mr. Penderecki
was there and we worked with him.
And it's a -- actually a really,
incredibly wonderful piece,
which I know you'll enjoy.
It's very atmospheric, very --
well, Emilie describes it very well.
She'll -- she'll talk about that
later, but it's a really beautiful
and very accessible piece
with gorgeous textures
and colors, so it's moving.
And I think the program that we
built around it also enhances that,
so the program's -- the program fits
together in a really lovely way.
But actually none of the pieces ends
with a big loud chord, everything --
everything ends softly, so that's --
that's something actually
-- I actually really like.
It requires a different attention
and a different reaction
from -- from all of you.
>> Michael Wilpers: If I could
follow up with one more question
about the experience at Marlboro.
One thing you learn when
you're visiting there,
spending time there is
egalitarian philosophy.
There -- there are words
I used when I was there
that I learned quickly not to use
and I wish I could
remember what they were.
It might have been, you know, master
musician and student or faculty
and student, certain words like
that, but those are really --
you leave them at the door,
maybe senior artists' use --
>> Marcy Rosen: We're called
senior members, but --
>> Michael Wilpers: --
senior members, yes.
But I was going to -- what
I was going to get to is
when you're rehearsing,
you know, [inaudible],
many of us have probably seen master
classes where there's no question,
in fact, that's the whole point that
the master is putting the student
in their place at many --
in a lot of -- often enough.
But I wonder if in these long
-- long weeks of rehearsal,
how you negotiate between the
musicians who have been around
and played the piece for decades,
and young musicians coming
in who are extremely talented, but
don't have that depth of experience
and yet, the ideal is you share
reflections and input equally.
So I just wonder if you
could tell a few anecdotes
or make some generalities about
how that plays out over the weeks.
>> Marcy Rosen: Well, I think
it's -- I mean, I'll speak --
I can only speak for myself,
but I think it's different
with each senior.
I -- you know, everybody runs
their groups a little differently
and I can tell you in --
in the years that I was
there with what people
that I consider my mentors, I pretty
much did everything they told me
to do.
And -- and I really learned from
that and I wanted to do that,
I wanted to hear Felix
Galimir tell me what to do.
And I wanted to take in his --
and I wanted to soak it up and --
and in fact, the soaking up of
the knowledge and the education
that I had from Felix Galimir and
Philipp Naegele and Pina Carmirelli
and [inaudible] and Rudolf
Serkin and Sasha Schneider
and Mischa Schneider and all these,
you know, the list is humongous.
And I was privileged to
get to work with them,
that's the whole reason I went
back was because I felt I wanted
to pass their -- I didn't want
their knowledge to die and I wanted
to pass it -- pass it on.
And so I'm like the next
step to keeping some
of those traditions alive.
And I want those traditions to be
carried on and so I tried to --
I don't teach in these things,
but you know, I think just that --
just sometimes I'll say
something that will inspire people
or the idea will come out in a
good way and that's all its doing.
I think we're just all working
together, but believe me,
it's a privilege for me to work
with Emilie, and David, and Danny,
and Anthony, who I also knew
when he was much younger
and it keeps you on your toes.
I mean, I have to play my
best to play with these guys
and it's -- it's really a privilege.
>> Anne E. McLean: I think another
thing that you guys always touch
on is the Marlboro tradition of
being faithful to the work itself.
And I was reading to --
reading about Serkin
learning this from Schoenberg.
He was involved with Schoenberg's
Society for Private Music in Vienna,
but they had a very close
affinity for study of the text.
And maybe this is a -- we could
segue and look at a couple
of items here, see if
our PowerPoint works.
Serkin was -- was 17
when he met Adolf Busch
and later married his daughter,
Irene -- that's correct.
>> Marcy Rosen: Irene.
>> Anne E. McLean: Irene -- and they
came to the United States very early
in -- our association was in
1933, but let's see if we can pull
up just a quick bunch of images.
We'll flip through them and then we
have a picture of the first program.
Oh, we already have
this one on there.
Okay, great.
Well, these are the founders.
This photo shows one unidentified
man, but there's Moyse,
a woodwind guru, flutist
and these are --
as you say, these were artists
who knew many of the composers.
Moyse, for example, knew [inaudible]
and a lot of famous artists.
Felix Galimir played with
Ravel and, you know, this --
this lore, as you say, was
passed on a great deal.
His wife, there's Hermann Busch,
the cellist and conductor,
who was also part of
Busch's string quartet,
which played here very early on.
Let's see, just some quick images
of Serkin, the animating spirit,
that they say, of Marlboro.
This is a CD which you can
buy, it's on the open market
and it has some wonderful recordings
from our archives that they --
some -- and some from other sources,
but some from our archives
too, which is great.
Moyse in rehearsal.
David Sawyer, yeah.
The Casals, maybe you
want to say anything
about the Casals tradition
at Marlboro?
>> Marcy Rosen: Well, unfortunately
he died just before I went,
so I never had any exposure to him.
But certainly the Schneider's
kept his -- his way of --
way of doing things alive
for a long, long time.
And there is a long history
of Casals doing master classes
and teaching and conducting
and so, that -- that --
some things have evolved
and gone on.
And so, unfortunately Casals was a
little bit back in the 70's now and,
you know, it's -- it's
sad, but true,
you can still find wonderful
videos and stuff of him.
They have -- there's a whole
collection of his master classes --
>> Anne E. McLean: And recordings.
>> Marcy Rosen: -- at Marlboro.
>> Anne E. McLean: Yeah, I think
-- were they part of the collection
on Bridge where I think
a couple [inaudible] --
>> Marcy Rosen: I think so, yeah.
>> Anne E. McLean: -- the 50th
anniversary release on Bridge.
And I remember reading a comment
about Casals saying that he worked
with orchestras to teach
them to play repertoire
as chamber music pieces
-- interesting.
Mitsuko Uchida and Richard Goode,
the two co-directors for awhile now.
Mitsuko is the main
director, sole director.
This is just a fun,
beautiful little illustration.
It's a great article, The Music
Mountain , an Alex Ross article
if you'd like to read
more about Marlboro.
These are -- yeah, from the --
>> Marcy Rosen: Thank goodness I'm
not wearing the same thing tonight.
[ Laughter ]
>> Anne E. McLean: And
formal nice things.
Sam Rhodes from the
Juilliard Quartet.
That's another thing we could talk
about a lot is how the influence
of Marlboro percolates out
through so many ensembles,
even for example, your quarter.
You want to say something
about the Momenta Quartet
and you studied the Koussevitzky
work that you mentioned earlier?
>> Emilie-Anne Gendron: Oh yeah,
well, we were emailing before,
today, and -- yeah, I just -- well,
I was just thinking in my head,
what is, you know, what are
the connections that I --
that I know of between like --
yeah, just Marlboro and
the Koussevitzky legacy.
And, I mean, first of all
like if you look down --
if you just like skim
the list of, you know,
all of the Koussevitzky
commissions that have been awarded,
it's like every major
name of the 20th
and 21st Century compositionally.
And some of the greatest
works of our time have come
out of the Koussevitzky commission
and -- yeah, my quartet --
Momenta Quartet, we
have had the great honor
of having two Koussevitzky
commissioned pieces written for us.
One by Kyung Chung, who is a
Malaysia-based composer and one
by Augustine Fernandez, who
is a Bolivian composer based
in the U.K. now.
And yeah, I was thinking just,
you know, about what are some
of the other pieces, you know,
that I know of chamber wise
that are Koussevitzky related and I
immediately thought of [inaudible]
which is one of the cornerstones of
the 20th Century quartet literature.
It's an amazing work
and I realized that --
my quartet plays it a lot now and
I realized that I got my start --
the reason I really love
this piece is because I spent
like six weeks working
on it at Marlboro
like four or five years ago.
And it's -- yeah, well,
that's an amazing piece.
But there is so much amazing
music that has come out --
that has percolated out of, you
know, the Koussevitzky legacy
and a lot of these
composers have been studied --
these composers and these works
have been studied for many,
many weeks of -- on end at Marlboro.
So, it's a nice connection.
>> Anne E. McLean: You know,
one of the things that we talked
about a little bit was how people
don't think of modern music so much
at Marlboro as I think
of the great masters,
but I think that's really wrong.
I think you guys have studied
a lot and the tradition
of studying these scores, I mean,
is a major part of your tradition.
>> Marcy Rosen: We have a
composer in residence every year.
I mean, I'm -- I'm
often involved in --
in those pieces, I don't
know why, but I am.
They make me [laughter].
But [inaudible] has been
there a couple of times,
Mr. Penderecki was there,
[inaudible] has been there.
Next year, Sofia Gubaidulina is
coming, which is kind of incredible.
>> Anne E. McLean: Nice.
>> Marcy Rosen: She never goes
anywhere, yeah, really like,
she literally never goes anywhere.
So it's really like a -- I think --
I think they're like going to
like put her in a little box
and preserve her and bring her over
because she's 90 something, or yeah.
We hope that she is in
good health for the summer.
So there's a huge, huge -- and it's
-- and it's becoming more and more.
We do -- we do more things.
Thomas Ades was there and --
>> David McCarroll: I just wanted to
add, also one of my best experiences
at Marlboro was actually
working with Sam Rhodes
on Carter, clarinet quintet.
Which -- well, I feel of
course, any of the music we work
on in Marlboro warrants that sort of
time, but you know, with that piece,
you literally cannot put it together
in much less time than that.
So it was -- yeah, and also
to learn it with Sam who --
who worked with him for decades
in the Juilliard Quartet.
That's the sort of experience that,
I don't know where you would
have anywhere else, actually.
>> Anne E. McLean: Let's
see what else we --
we'll move on from
there, just a second.
That's a classic photograph
that you see a lot, Van Cliburn
and James Levine at age 12.
[ Laughter ]
Alexander Schneider.
>> And Casals.
>> Anne E. McLean: And
Casals, look at in the back.
And back to quartets for a minute,
here at the library, of course,
we have -- we are a quartet mecca
really and so many of the quartets
that had been associated with
the Marlboro legacy have passed
through here.
For example, Alexander Schneider's
own quartet, he had a quartet
for a number of years and Hermann
Busch was part of that actually.
And of course, the
Juilliard and the Emerson
and many other quartets have had one
or more members learn their life's
history and work and calling
from these great artists.
So let's see, a couple more.
Blanche Honegger Moyse --
did you ever go to those --
>> Marcy Rosen: Oh, sure.
>> Anne E. McLean: Yeah, I was going
to say what their tradition was.
>> Marcy Rosen: She did a Bach
Cantata concert every summer,
which was -- it's actually the --
the Marlboro players
didn't -- didn't do them.
She brought in her own orchestra
mostly because we didn't have time
to devote to what she
wanted the time --
but the singers would all sing
and really inspirational to hear,
the Bach Cantatas in that
setting and anywhere.
But she -- she did
it very beautifully.
>> Anne E. McLean: Rehearsal images.
>> Marcy Rosen: That's
the -- that was Felix.
>> Anne E. McLean: And this is very
nice, this is a project you did
at the Greene Space WQXR in
New York, a beautiful venue.
One of the touring
ensembles from Marlboro.
Michael, when did you start
presenting the Marlboro group?
>> Michael Wilpers: We
started in the fall of 1993,
the Meyer family had long history
with Marlboro musicians
and the festival.
And the director of the museum
at the time, Milo Beach,
was good friends with both Katherine
Graham and Elizabeth Meyer.
And as long as we're looking
at those older pictures,
I was going to mention
that Elizabeth Meyer,
the wife of Eugene Meyer, former
owner of the Washington Post,
former first head of
the World Bank and Chair
of the Federal Reserve
and a financier earlier.
She and -- and Eugene
Meyer collected Chinese art
with Freer back in the
very early 20th Century.
And after Freer died and years
later during the war, Agnes Meyer --
according to Frank Solomon, let's --
who I was told just all about
this a couple summers ago --
when Serkin and the
Busch's had left Germany,
in the middle of the war
and gone to Switzerland.
I think, were eager
to get out of Europe
and Agnes Meyer went personally
to the state department to lobby
for getting their Visa's
put through.
And that's how they finally got to
the U.S. permanently during the war.
And then their -- one of their
sons, Bill Meyer, became --
and his wife became supporters
of Marlboro and went regularly.
So when the Meyer Auditorium
reopened in 1993, after renovation
with funds from Katharine Graham and
the Meyer family, it was renamed,
the Eugene and Agnes
Meyer Auditorium.
And the grandchildren of Eugene
and Agnes helped start the Meyer
concert series on the provision
that it regularly include the
musicians from Marlboro every year.
And we -- Milo Beach [inaudible]
had no trouble agreeing to that
and so we've had Marlboro
there every year
for the last 20 some years.
>> Anne E. McLean: And it
is a wonderful segue from us
and this is part of the history
that Michael and I talked
about when we first had this
idea to share the project
for your anniversary year.
And our anniversary too, was that
we began presenting Marlboro in 1980
with great pleasure for something
we call the Saturday Series and then
when -- with I think, the first
performers were Hiroko Yajima
and Andras Schiff, among others.
>> Marcy Rosen: Gary Hoffman.
>> Anne E. McLean:
Gary Hoffman, exactly.
Boy, you have a memory,
a great memory.
And then we had to shut down
our operation as many of you
in the audience remember because we
had the whole building renovated,
so there was an eight year, nine
-- eight and half, nine year period
when we could do no
concerts and thankfully,
you were able to -- to take it on.
Let's see, let's amp this
part, oh, that's a nice one.
Let's see if we can get out of this.
[Inaudible] -- yeah
[inaudible] and Isidore Cohen,
one of my favorite people.
I got a kick out of reading in
your bread book that it said,
Mr. Cohen would look at the
musicians very carefully
and he's say, "Well,
what do you think?
Should there be a [inaudible] here?"
Okay, so end that and we'll
escape and then minimize.
Now one more thing I was looking
forward to showing you and that is
down at the bottom, this is the
image of the first Marlboro program.
This is the -- it's so sweet
that it says the first appearance
in America, but it's just very,
very heartening to see this.
And one thing that's
interesting back to our ideas
about modern music,
Mr. Busch insisted
that there be some hot
off the press music.
So for example, he included
[inaudible] and then also
in another program he had a
brand new, [inaudible] piece
which was literally -- literally
hot off the press, it was 1933
and the concert date was 1933.
And in the letters back
and forth to our --
our managers, he stressed
that he wanted
to have a modern music element,
which is really interesting to see.
What other things about the
current experience that --
would you guys like to talk about?
And then we can move also into
the music for tonight too.
What -- are there new projects for
Marlboro, like this whole thing
at QXR was kind of
fascinating to see that happen.
>> Marcy Rosen: I was there.
Were you there -- well,
actually what that concert is
when this year is the
50th anniversary
of the touring program -- 65th
anniversary of the festival
and the 50th anniversary
of the touring program.
And so, it was celebrating
the touring program
that we did a nice concert there.
It was broadcast and so just
to getting generating some --
some hoopla among the celebration,
so that's basically what it's --
what it was for and we --
Anthony played and I
played with Jonathan Biss.
We did -- and Robin Scott,
we did a Mendelssohn trio.
And so, it was a -- it
was a wonderful event
as almost every event that we
do for Marlboro is wonderful.
This is wonderful.
We played at -- we
played at Carnegie Hall
on Monday night, that was wonderful.
We played in a funny little library
on Sunday in Greenwich, Connecticut,
but that was wonderful too.
>> Anne E. McLean: And we
have all your archives here,
at least many decades worth.
We don't have the recent
ones, so we need to get those.
Any -- is there any chance
of you guys moving to MP3's
to distribute now or
what's your current thinking
about your recording projects
online -- distribute of any kind?
No.
>> Emilie-Anne Gendron:
I'm sure that will --
that's its whole dedicated
department at Marlboro.
>> Anne E. McLean:
It really is, yeah.
>> Emilie-Anne Gendron: Like
they have a team of, you know,
audio engineers and archivists
and they probably have a
lot of that in the works.
They're probably thinking ahead,
but -- but we don't know personally.
>> Anne E. McLean: Yeah, yeah.
Wasn't Paula [inaudible]
part of that in --
for a long time and
then Mischa Schneider?
>> Marcy Rosen: Mischa
Schneider was the sort of head
of the Marlboro Recording Society.
And so, recordings that were made --
and there hasn't been
as many in-studio recordings
done in the last years.
I hope we'll get back to that,
I don't know what's going
on with that, but we used to make
recordings of some of the pieces
that we would perform in the summer.
And Mischa was the -- was the
producer, so he did that and --
[inaudible] I think funded it.
>> Michael Wilpers: I think the --
>> Marcy Rosen: --
I think funded it.
>> Michael Wilpers: -- the audience
here might be interested in knowing
that the -- Marlboro did launch a
pretty ambitious online recording
resource and you can hear a lot of
historic recordings from Marlboro
and it's completely indexed
by performer and composer.
And you can -- it's -- and it's
always being added to every year.
In fact --
>> Anne E. McLean:
On their website, or?
>> Michael Wilpers: Yeah.
>> Marcy Rosen: I didn't know you
could listen to recordings on that.
>> Anne E. McLean:
I didn't know that.
>> Michael Wilpers: I don't know
what -- which recordings they have,
I believe they're form the
festival, but [inaudible] daughter,
who's on the local board
of Marlboro, was very proud
of this and informed me of it.
And so I -- and she asked me
to announce it before a concert
of Marlboro's just
a couple years ago.
So it's a -- and it's always growing
and they're very happy about it.
>> Anne E. McLean: Before we move
to the talking more about the music,
anybody want to comment
about napkin throwing?
It's something you read about,
but you are the experts.
>> Emilie-Anne Gendron: I
mean, I remember the first --
like after my first summer there,
like it was like definitely a good
month -- it was like late September
and I found myself at a
restaurant, like you know, with --
in public and I had taken my napkin
and just instinctively was starting
to create a napkin ball
like under the table.
And then I realized this is not
the place, I'm not at Marlboro.
That's the only comment I have.
There's --
>> Anne E. McLean: It's
a time honored tradition.
All -- all ages, all backgrounds,
all instruments apparently,
you know, even Mr. Serkin.
>> David McCarroll: Yeah, no it
really -- really does happen.
I couldn't quite believe it before
I got there, but it -- it does.
>> Anne E. McLean: There's a --
or somebody that had to be
shielded with an umbrella.
There's this --
>> Marcy Rosen: That's
a very funny story.
There was the -- when -- after Mr.
Serkin died, the very beginning,
there was a -- there was a
trio of artistic directors.
And one of those artistic directors,
who I don't think I'll name,
they wanted to do away
with the napkin balls.
It was not something that
he appreciated and he felt
that he shouldn't have
to be bombarded by this.
So a napkin free zone was set up
[laughter] in the dining hall,
it was a -- it was like there
was a row of music stands
on which there were signs
that said, "Napkin free zone,"
which is just really like,
asking people to -- to do it.
And -- and we have this
wonderful librarian, her --
who's name I can mention,
her name was Shirley Weekly.
She had been also a fixture, a
Marlboro fixture for 40 years
and she was also the
librarian at Curtis.
A lovely lady, she had some -- she
didn't like -- she loved the --
well, let's say, she didn't
like the napkin balls either,
so she hadn't eaten in
the dining room for,
I don't know, 20 years or more.
She always took her tray and ate
in another room off the
-- off the dining hall.
So, this night that -- of this
inaugural napkin free zone,
Shirley Weekly came back into the
dining hall, thinking she was safe
and at one point, and I --
and I believe I know who
engineered the whole thing.
And I -- as it happens, the
person who -- who was --
who was initiating this happens
to be a close friend of mine.
Then I -- it was -- I was not in
favor of this things, but I --
was sitting and having dinner with
-- with them on that side of the --
the other side of the barrier.
The entire other side of the room in
unison , got up and threw napkins.
And Shirley Weekly never at
in the dining hall again.
And -- and that artistic
director also didn't stay
around for a very long
time, that was unfortunate.
Not -- I don't know if
it was because of that.
It was not a good beginning.
>> Michael Wilpers: Well,
I think hearing this
and seeing how much fun the
musicians have at Marlboro,
helped me realize where the
spirit comes from that I had seen
on stage for so many years.
Where the -- these musicians clearly
and unmistakably enjoy
what you're doing.
I mean, even if some music is --
is very serious, it's
done in a certain manner
that is a real passion,
that comes across.
I think it's cultivated in part
by the festival atmosphere.
It is the farthest thing from
workman like or drudgery.
And I think it says -- it may sound
frivolous, these kind of games
and antics and things,
but it definitely works.
I mean, it makes the groups
that come out of Marlboro stand
out for the sheer enjoyment of
-- of what it is you're doing.
>> Anne E. McLean: Before we, sort
of [inaudible] give you a chance
to -- a chance to go back and warm
up, do you want to talk a little bit
about the music and maybe
about the Penderecki.
Emilie, you were saying
that you had some thoughts
on the texture and everything.
>> Emilie-Anne Gendron: Oh, well,
ultimately -- ultimately, you know,
the music will more than speak
for itself, but you know,
the Penderecki is sort of an
incredible work of just in the kind
of atmosphere that
it creates and the --
the gamut of moods that it explores.
As many of you may know,
Penderecki -- his --
Penderecki's music figured into
some of the big film scores
of the past few decades,
such as The Shining or
even The Exorcist and --
and numerous other films.
He's written -- he sort of made
that leap into pop culture.
I learned he even has an
asteroid named after him,
which must be like a great honor.
But like the thing about --
yeah, I think maybe because he's
so effective writing for
film is that he's so adept
at creating just an all
encompassing mood, you know,
whatever that mood might be.
And the piece itself is -- it's
quite short, its four movements,
three of them are attacka
[phonetic], they go consecutively.
You can't really hear
when they stop and start.
And each movement is
sort of a tip of the hat,
in a way to different
composers of the past.
You can -- you'll see
in your programs,
the movement titles
are very evocative.
There's a ironic waltz,
serenade that reminds you
of something you might hear
in a [inaudible] Schoenberg.
The last movement, for instance,
is -- entitled Abscheid,
which means farewell in German.
That's a very strong Beethoven
[inaudible] reference built in.
And so, yeah, and as Marcy
said, it really captures some
of that same sort of
a autumnal feeling
that you get in the [inaudible].
It -- they're very similar
and they're kindred spirits
in many ways, so hopefully this
will enhance your listening of --
of all the pieces in the program.
>> Anne E. McLean: Wonderful, and
also, so you mentioned [inaudible],
these musicians, the
touring ensemble
from Marlboro will be coming
back in May, again with Michael
as co-sponsor and they'll
be doing that work here
for then -- for that concert.
Any questions for the
musicians and Michael -- Roger?
>> Yes, the publicity mentioned that
Penderecki was influence -- was --
that there's a relationship to
the Schubert c major quintet,
and that's one of my favorite
things, so I'm wondering
if you'd like to talk about that.
>> Anne E. McLean:
Yeah, I looked that up.
I think it was more again,
with this sort of idea
of [inaudible] to Vienna
in some way.
I don't think that it's -- it's not
actually, explicitly referencing it
in any way, except for maybe
that like some of the moods
that it creates that are
so untouchable sometimes.
I sense some of the same
depth in both the pieces,
but I think it's more abstract,
you know, on an abstract level
that it pays almost to that piece.
>> Anne E. McLean: Anybody else?
About, let's see -- oh, and
while we're just thinking one --
maybe one more question.
Any comments on the Brahms
that you're -- for tonight?
This is a kind of a
great, great classic work.
Have you done this before in --
>> David McCarroll:
Well, I have, but it's --
I mean, I think we all feel the
same, it's just a great honor to get
to play such a piece six times
in a row and to work on it.
There really is no other piece
like it or quite with that depth
of feeling or special
place in his life
and also what it expresses,
so we're enjoying it.
>> I'm curious about
[inaudible] -- oh, sorry.
I'm curious about
cross-fertilization between seniors
who may be wind players,
vocalists, string players --
to what extent do they
extend their --
their nuances to other
groups of players?
That is, with a woodwind
player, a flutist, a singer,
[inaudible] string
group on some occasion.
Yeah.
>> Marcy Rosen: No [laughter].
>> Anne E. McLean:
Interesting question, yeah.
>> Marcy Rosen: No, but
we would coach them.
No, that's -- I'm totally getting
silly because we have a concert
in -- no, what -- certainly
[inaudible] was a great influence
on a lot of people at Marlboro.
And Charlie Neidich is a -- is a
current influence on lots of people
in both because of his character and
because he's a really interesting
and very intelligent
musician that has --
he has a whole well of knowledge
that you just are shocked
by all the time.
And, you know, certainly
Benita Valente is there as a --
as a singer for -- as a coach for
the singers, but if you're working
with a singer in a chamber music
work, she is at your rehearsal.
So she does have some cross
fertilization in terms of working
on Schoenberg second quartet, for
instance, that has soprano in it.
Or last summer, we did a [inaudible]
piece with -- for soprano.
It's like basically a concerto
for soprano and cello, and done --
does have an orchestra part,
but she wrote a piano version
of it, so we did it as a trio.
But so, Benita was there listening
to all of those rehearsals as well
and it was certainly very
helpful to have her there.
So, there is definitely, you know,
we don't -- we don't, you know,
segregate -- even -- we even talk
to singers all during --
all during the summer.
We've really considered them as
normal people [laughter] that --
>> Anne E. McLean: Well, that
might be a good note to end on.
Okay, well, thank you very, very
much in music and [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at Loc.gov.